[Music]
all right let's go to casey
in boise what's up casey
hey dr john how are you man
well not too bad hanging in there
excellent what's up dude
so i uh i just got done reading your
your new book uh really enjoyed it
there's only like only like 10 people
bought that book man so thank you for
being one of them
oh that's all right i loved it thank you
the uh we're reading it though the the
section where you talk about kind of
having a box where you have a small
number of people you really confide in
you know you have a spiritual advisor
and a close friend
you know one or two and you also include
your wife in there and
i guess
my question is i feel like i i can't
include my my wife in there and um you
know i really want to because she's my
spouse yeah i love her but um just
really struggling with how to how to
include her in that man so let me um
back out real quick and explain for
folks um if you're new to the show um
this idea of a box on your counter if
you will comes from a conversation i had
in a counseling class and i was in a
back to during my i was getting my phd
in counseling and we were in a classroom
and
we're talking about who hurts our
feelings and um ultimately landed on i
people can can fire me and take away my
livelihood someone can shoot me and kill
me somebody can um break my leg right
but ultimately i am responsible i get to
choose who hurts me
and i realized in that class i give had
was giving access to everybody there's
people on the internets i didn't know
um politicians um friends of a friend
40 people that i was a a you know a
colleague with i was giving permission
for everybody and i was walking around
raged out hurt feeling sad
every time i come up for air somebody
else would say i realized i was letting
everybody in side in my chest if you
will to hurt my feelings
and so the exercise was
limit it to five
and so i started saying okay who do i
let speak into my life and good grief so
i cut out all of the parents of my
students because they would call in and
they'd say something like you
you failed my kid because and i would be
crushed by that i didn't mean to feel i
didn't want to feel your kid
finally i was like dj i'm not giving you
you don't get to hurt my feelings you
know you can say i'm i am crummy
professional camera my feelings
i was giving access to my in-laws to my
parents
they'd give me parenting advice and i'd
be like i'm the worst
i took them out and so ultimately in my
little box i ended up with
the person um one or two people who were
that i really valued their wisdom they
were older than me they were mentors but
they were spiritual they were people
that i trusted hey i'm about to make
this big life change what do you think
um
and then i had several close friends
that i've been ride or die with for a
long time i think i got mine down to six
i don't remember exactly what it was but
and then the first person was my wife
and i actually called them including my
wife and said hey i'm giving you access
to me
and um this is i'm a tough texas male i
don't know i'm not supposed to talk like
this but um you now have permission to
hurt me you have permission to speak
into my life so if you see me doing
something stupid call me out like you
always do
um if you think i'm being dumb or the
clothes i'm wearing are ridiculous you
have permission to say something i'm
gonna listen to you
and uh my wife was a key person to put
in there so that's that's the backstory
there so then back to casey my obvious
question is man
why can't you
why can't you put her there why is that
so terrifying
well
you know i had a really stable childhood
growing up and very you know normal and
secure and loving and so i didn't have a
lot of you know as your book talks about
you know trauma childhood trauma or
anything like that
you know of all the people that have
hurt me
the most it's kind of been been her
and
yikes
and so it's just really been a struggle
and how has she hurt you okay
um
you know
well she's
tried leaving twice
she just uh puts the kids
you know
over over me ever since the you know
first kid was born and
you know she's just uh
just not a priority that way
and when we try to have a deep
discussion or
really open up it usually turns
argumentative and
um
you know it's just just not a very
secure
place for that kind of thing
i'm sorry man
it's been pretty tough yeah
i mean i can't i'm just i can't wrap my
head around that man that hurts dude
um how long have you all been married
uh 17 years oh man
and that the the trade leaving it's been
twice within the last probably two years
okay
and i'm hearing that all over the
country it's been a lot of chaos the
last few years and um so it's been a
mess of course have you ever gone to
counseling together
yeah we we did the first time when it
when it really came to a head about two
years ago you know we went through
counseling and you know that was
very good and very encouraging and
you know
but the the counselor was
kind of pretty hard on on her
and because the whole time i'm thinking
am i doing everything right you know and
i write in my thought process
and the counselor kind of and it's a
counselor that she chose and
you know but yet the counselor was kind
of affirmed you know i'm trying to do
everything right my marriage and my
family and in life and
you know she was the one that had a
bunch of things to work on and
and
[Music]
you know she didn't really respond
very well to that you know she said yeah
sound sounds good but then nothing
changed
is she seeing somebody else
no i don't think so okay has she before
in the marriage uh
no not that i'm aware of and i've never
seen any evidence of that
i'm just trying to
i'm not accusing her i'm just trying to
see all the variables here in a short
time frame but
yeah
here's here doesn't think very deeply
about things you know
yeah
i get that but that's different
um it sounds like she has no interest in
helping meet your needs
and that her whole life is
i'm going to do things the way i want
them done
and if i can't get them that way i'm
going to storm off by myself i'm going
to take my ball and go home
and
um
i mean we could have a whole
woo conversation about the wounded child
and all that but that's a very childish
response well then i'm just gonna leave
then you know what i mean
um and so
here's where i'm torn man i'm torn in
two ways number one you do not put
people in that quote-unquote in that in
that mythical box here that you don't
trust that you can't be vulnerable with
you can't open up to
and also
your marriage is really on life support
right now and i know you know that
um
it sounds like yeah that's one of those
moments to sit down and have those
conversations is like why
we are now adults choosing to live this
life and it's miserable why are we doing
this can we decide to make this
different
and the heartbreaking
answer to that question is
unfortunately
i don't want to do that with you
and so what i'll tell you is there's
this weird chicken or the egg thing that
happens
with that box if you will
where somebody hurts you
that you love
and forgiveness is hard
grief is hard like reconciliation saying
i'm sorry can be hard all those things
are hard
but then you pull that person out of
your box
they feel that gap
and it creates a
just a tiny shim
but of space and that space just grows
over time
see what i'm saying
and so um
it just feels like one of those moments
and you've probably heard me say this on
the show where you just got to turn all
the lights on turn all the music off the
dance gotta stop for a minute we just
gonna say dude what are we doing
because right now we're adults and we're
choosing to live a less than life and i
don't underst that seems like a bizarre
choice to be making
you're choosing to not meet my needs i'm
still trying to meet yours
and i i can't imagine this doesn't
affect your sex life it doesn't affect
your work
life it doesn't affect the just going
home and having home be a warm safe
place to drop your shoulders and go ah
but instead you get off work and you go
home and now it's like another job right
yeah it's uh you know and she doesn't
openly acknowledge that there's a
problem she looks around at our friends
and our family in the world and goes
well we're at marriage it's fine there's
nothing wrong with it it's all good
i'm just like there's just deep no
things aren't i don't think they are
so if you came we sat down tonight after
dinner and said hey um
i'd like to go back and see a counselor
again with the two of us
because things might be fine but fine's
not good enough for me i want things to
be incredible
and i'm willing to do some work are you
willing to do some work what would she
say
i i think she would say
that things are fine the way they are
and
we've already been down this road
and
or she would say you know i'm the bad
one you're the good one i should
be yourself up and say well i'm the one
that has all the problems and yeah
that's like that's just like nonsense
stuff into the marriage yeah yeah
that's just a that's just a throwaway
oh it's just all me huh you know what i
mean and then you back up and go no it's
me too i uh you know i sometimes leave
the toothpaste cap out that's just like
a that's just a move you know what i
mean
uh okay here's here's the hard and i
didn't see this call going in this
direction
um
what is your or what
what i mean by that is
i can hear it in you you're getting
closer and closer to an or what moment
what is your or what moment meaning
i need you to do this things around here
have to change or what
are you gonna leave
i
i i don't think my or what is is to
leave because i've made a
you know biblical covenant with her in
marriage and i've talked to a lot of to
those other people in my box about it
and the consensus kind of is it's like
well marriage is the the highest thing
so you do whatever it takes to
keep it together and keep it keep it
going but i always wonder at what cost
absolutely
and i really struggle with that and and
i want her to be in the box i want her
to be closer she's i do love her deeply
but it's just she's not true she's not
safe she's not trustworthy right
yeah so here's the here's what you can
do right now in this in this season
um
if i'm you i would go find somebody a
professional to talk to on your own
um in this variable that's the only
person you can you can
be about because you need some clarity
moving forward
i haven't expanded this is completely
john doloni here okay this is a personal
thing i have an expanded view of
infidelity
of um i think as for for people who are
in biblical covenant marriages
um
this idea of
unfaithfulness
is much deeper than
did so and so hook up with somebody else
it's much much deeper than that
faithfulness and fidelity is i'm all in
physically i'm not going to sleep with
somebody else
emotionally
um spirit like i'm in
and when i'm part of
the reason why this unity isn't working
here
i am going to from a point of fidelity
and a point of faithfulness to this
agreement we made i'm going to make some
changes in my life even when they're
ugly and messy and really really hard
and so faithfulness to me is a much
broader picture than somebody slept with
somebody else
okay now
that's not shared by
ministers and pastors all over the place
that's fine
what that means is there's millions and
millions and millions and millions of
couples who haven't stepped out on their
marriage haven't kissed anybody else
and
they say i'm being faithful
yet they have
absolutely no
play they're not doing anything to help
love their partner better to help make
this union stronger to say i'm sorry and
do work on themselves that they need to
do so that the whole unit can be well
and by the way these kids are absorbing
this stuff
they're they're just absorbing it and
they're coming to understand well i
guess this is just what marriage is i
guess this is how mom's role i guess
this is just what dads do
and so this whole idea of faithfulness
and fidelity is a much much bigger thing
than who put what where
it is i'm all in and right now casey
dude
i didn't expect this call to get here
man
i don't blame you
it's not safe to put her in there right
now
and
the long-term viability of your marriage
is on really thin ice
and so what i'll tell you is at some
point something here changes
and when i know something's going to
change
i always want to be on the proactive
side when i if i have a retaining wall
at my in my at the back of my farm and i
see it starting to bend
i don't want to wait till it collapses
i'm going to call somebody out i'm going
to save the money up i'm going to call
somebody out and have them come build it
and dig it out um otherwise i'm gonna
have a huge mess on my hands that wall's
getting getting dealt with one way or
the other i want to deal with it on as
far up the front end as i possibly can
sorry brother we'll be thinking about
you